pas
[Musique]
et regardez moi ça on y est bienvenue à
guillaume votre père n'a jamais voulu me
raconter sa vie
[Musique]
mes enfants ont besoin d'un toit et il
faut que ce soit ce taux là
vous croire
[Musique]
oui oui
qui a hausse est rempli de clichés
extraordinaire
il faut que tu les écoutes elles sujet
tu as entendu
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gaudy
j'y crois pas
mais comment c'est possible
[Musique]
c'est pas un jeu on sait par quoi sert
séquelles
on m'avait été dit
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui vous
il ya une créature qui vaut ses clés une
créature maléfique
[Musique]
ces clés sont pas des joueurs
ce sont des arbres
ces clés
c'est notre héritage
c'est quelque chose qui nous lie à papa
le passé ne nous quitte jamais
tu as pour essayer qu échapper
il est toujours là peu importe ce que tu
crois savoir à coup de sifflet
dutronc